freddie no decisions last time out
against cincinnati pittskill got away
from a little bit five innings only two
hits three runs six punch outs
has never made a start against the white
sox one relief appearance last year
three scoreless innings
and a swing at a miss in this game
starts with a strikeout
they've hit 33 homers in the last 18
games
as peralta dots the inside corner
good one is wrong up a backwards k to
start his night goodwin's barking at the
home plate up fire
lucas giolito on for his 20th start he's
looking for his ninth win as zra a touch
below four
a lot of strikeouts 133 of them 113
innings and as you can see left-handers
because of that change-up well they
don't fare very well against him the
opponent's o-p-s on the first pitch of
an at-bat
as abraham makes the pick over at first
and he wins the race
against colton wong for out number one
not trying to pull the ball so much
starting to elevate the ball get the
ball in the air a little bit and yelling
rips one through a base hit adamus will
turn head to third
and yelich
with a single the brewers in business
here in the first inning
[Applause]
to second base garcia the pit tim the
turn double play
there is a first pitch swung out there
is a ground ball we'll go to the second
tonight already with the slider
2-2 pitch monkada
pops it up
shift was on so it's a very difficult
play and peralta makes the catch the
pitcher
normally that'd be routine for a third
baseman but the brewers
had uria's way over in the grass in
right field
peralta says pitchers are people too
yeah and he makes the play
lace to left field that was a slider
that caught a fat part of the plate the
ball boy tried to dodge it i don't know
if he got a piece of it andrew's gonna
end up at second and i do believe that
may have kicked the ball boy on the way
by the way yelich ended up playing that
ball regardless it's a one-out double
one ball two strikes
two outs in the second
and down he goes
grabbing a
high stress pitches in the second for
peralta
but they utilize the pitcher batting for
himself and get out of it love a good
check swing controversy
on the ground to third it's makata it's
garcia it's two
well that's two double plays which is a
really good thing save on pitches
that was an easy one it was hit right at
yuan
that's about as routine of five four
three as you're gonna see what he has in
mind for him here no balls two strikes
and did he go he did good bounce back to
the catcher tomas fortunate he's able to
make the play to secure the strikeout
seven pitch inning for peralta
and good fortune for darvayas
[Music]
1-2 high heat and a good sign a high
fastball gets a strikeout for giolito
yelich will lead off the fourth and here
is the first strikeout for giolito
tonight he did it on his signature
four seem faster
and nobody was really talking about when
it happened
not a big deal turned into a big deal a
swing and a miss monkana strikes out
freddie peralta
with his fifth key
well it's been a while for freddie but
that fastball right on the outside
corner and you see montana underneath it
brewers have a big chance right here
they're loaded up for rowdy teles
and right off the end of the bat into
center field a base head
garcia will score they go station to
station
rowdy teles with an rbi single the
brewer's on the board first and he did
go with a change of it was up in his own
allowing tolez to get a bat on it didn't
hit it hard nothing really hit all that
hardness in it
[Applause]
at third base side that stays in the
ballpark and ends the inning so it's one
run but nothing more on faces loaded one
out and we'll go to the fifth
and a nice outing for
freddie peralta and now adrian hauser is
tonight's gruber law offices one call
that's all called to the pen yeah last
start for adrian was back on july 16.
that was at cincinnati four innings four
hits four runs
on the ground marias goes to second no
problem nicely done hauser gets a couple
of ground ball outs strands a runner at
first
struck him out a second change up that
one elevated and a big first out for
lucas in the fifth
[Music]
one and one
slider he just missed it he turned and
was so frustrated that he just missed it
and the innings over one nothing after
five in a well-pitched ball game
teles lines one right field that is down
to the wall that goes
rowley tellez on his way to second base
it is a stand-up double
two for three today for rowdy teles two
on two out three and two for hiro
he got him on a fastball
lucas came back and what a pitch this
was
he backed up 95 with another 95 and this
one he threw right by him to get out of
the inning
02 pitch on the ground arenas has it
coming home
and the tag
in plenty of time now has popped it on
the leg
that's a big out to get that's a good
decision by erase you're not going to
turn two on that
a couple of hops to third base around
the horn no chance
now to turn the double play on tim
anderson so he goes home and now the
former white sox
avi garcia
is one out of three tonight 3-2 pitch
big chopper over the head
and uh the throw to first is in time but
a run scores
man was that some play by garcia yeah no
kidding
getting the ball in the gloves that's
one thing but getting it out of the
glove and on its way to first base
accurately that's another play
altogether it's two nothing brewers
three-two pitch teles takes ball four
it's a bases loaded walk and it's
three-nothing milwaukee now nine walks
in the game for this inning tony
lawrence is going to have a conversation
with ryan burr here
i think he wants to talk with john libka
and there he goes so he just got the
heat hole from the home plate umpire
tyrone taylor bases loaded three-nothing
brewers two runs are in
and a swing and a drive down the
left-field line is it fair foul it is a
fair ball
tyro
taylor a grand slam
first slam of his career in the big
leagues
and taylor with a knockout punch in the
seventh inning i think they are just in
the process of yelling at john litka
from the sox dugout he can throw anybody
out all he wants but he's missed a bunch
of pitches tonight i haven't seen tim
this upset in a while but there's been
some real bad calls and it definitely
was tim because he's now giving john
lipka an earful and letting dan iasonia
hear about it as well the crew chief
andrew vaughn center field
deep out there and up and out of here
for andrew vaughn on a three-hit night
and the sox get one back
with two out in the eighth that was a
bomb to center field at
the 11th for andrew
and this ball game is ova
as gustave
picks up the strikeout to end it